La ecuación "y" es igual a "3x" entre 4 más 9, intersecta al eje de las "y" en el (0, 9).
Y bueno, cuando decimos que intersecta al eje de las "y" estamos refiriéndonos a qué es lo que pasa
cuando "x" vale 0 y si te das cuenta,
cuando "x" vale 0 entonces esta parte
de aquí, este "3x" entre 4, esto de aquí
se hace 0 y por lo tanto, solamente me quedaría
con este más 9, por lo tanto, intersectamos
al eje de las "y" en el punto (0, 9) y lo
podemos ver de una manera sencilla,
reescribe la ecuación para expresar
"x" en términos de "y", "x" es igual...
y bueno, como no podemos trabajar aquí, entonces
déjame sacar mi libreta de apuntes, perfecto,
para poder trabajar este problema.
Y esencialmente como lo que queremos es reescribir
la ecuación para expresar a "x" en términos
de "y", realmente lo que necesitamos es despejar
a "x", aislar "x", por lo tanto déjame copiar
esta ecuación aquí abajo para poderla trabajar.
Y me va a quedar...
déjame poner esta herramienta...
me va a quedar que "y"... "y" es igual a "3x",
ok, entre 4 y a esto le sumamos 9...
y a esto le sumamos 9.
Ahora, si lo que queremos es despejar a "x",
lo primero que voy a hacer es restar 9 de
ambos lados de esta ecuación, para que este
9 se vaya del otro lado o lo cancelemos de
este lado derecho, por lo tanto voy a restar
9 de este lado y de este lado también voy
a restar 9, date cuenta que lo que estamos
haciendo es que de este lado derecho,
más 9 menos 9 se van a cancelar, déjame tacharlo
bien y de este otro lado va a pasar el 9 con
signo negativo y por lo tanto me va a quedar que "y"...
que "y" menos 9...
déjame ponerlo con este mismo color,
"y" menos 9 es exactamente igual...
es exactamente igual a "3x" entre 4... entre 4.
Ahora, se me ocurre quitar este 4 de aquí y para quitar este 4 que te parece si multiplico todo por 4,
voy a multiplicar esta parte por 4, ok, pero también voy a hacer lo mismo del lado izquierdo
para que se mantenga la ecuación, voy a
multiplicar esta parte por 4 ....
y es más, déjame mover un poco mi pantalla...
vamos a mover un poco la pantalla para acá,
para que pueda multiplicar por 4, así que
multipliquemos esta parte también por 4
y de esta forma, 4 y 4 se van a ir y me va a
quedar que 4...
y déjame ponerlo aquí...
4 que va a multiplicar a "y" menos 9...
que va a multiplicar a "y" menos 9...
menos 9, esto es igual a "3x",
esto debe de ser igual a 3 veces "x".
Y ahora nos falta este 3,
este 3 lo voy a pasar del otro lado dividiendo de ambos lados entre 3, entonces vamos a dividir este lado
entre 3 y voy a dividir también este otro
lado entre 3, por lo tanto este 3 y este 3
se van a ir y solamente me voy a quedar con
"x", que justo lo que quería,
"x" es igual a 4 que multiplica a "y" menos 9,
todo esto dividido entre 3.
Por lo tanto, antes de que se nos olvide,
lo voy a apuntar justo acá en mi navegador
de internet, déjame traerlo por acá y 4
por "y" menos 9 entre 3...
lo voy a apuntar justo aquí...
justo aquí me piden que maneje esa misma
información entonces lo voy a poner, 4 que
multiplica a "y" menos 9, ok,
y todo esto estaba dividido entre 3, ¿no es así?
Perfecto, ya tengo aquí cuanto vale la ecuación para "x",
como expresar a "x" en términos
de "y", ahora lo que nos preguntan es
¿cuál es la intersección con el eje "x" de esta ecuación? y para esto déjame regresar de nuevo aquí,
a mi bloc de notas para que lo podamos trabajar.
Ahora, esencialmente esta ecuación de aquí
se ve de la siguiente manera, nosotros sabíamos
que esto, esto es una recta, por lo tanto
se vería más o menos así, si yo la grafico
me va a quedar algo así y éste es uno de
mis ejes, éste es otro mis ejes...
déjame poner que éste es mi eje "y", ok...
éste es mi eje "y" y por aquí tengo a mi eje "x",
ok y bueno, si yo graficara esta ecuación sabemos que es una recata que intersecta aquí
en el valor de 9, al eje las "y", así
que si la dibujamos con otro color...
déjame tomar este color y bueno, si te das
cuenta tiene pendiente positiva y por lo tanto
es una recta que se ve más o menos...
más o menos, así...
se va a ver más o menos así mi recta y bueno,
quiero que te des cuenta que cuando nosotros
nos fijamos en la intersección con el eje
de las "y", estamos hablando de cuando "x"
es 0, es decir, nos referimos a este punto
de aquí, pero si yo me quiero fijar en cual
es la intersección con el eje de las "x",
bueno, estoy pensando en cuando "y" vale 0,
cuando "y" vale 0 es cuando no subimos
ni bajamos, es decir, me estoy refiriendo a
este punto de aquí. Y por lo tanto,
lo que tengo que hacer es de esta ecuación de aquí ver cuánto vale "x" cuando "y" vale 0...
déjame borrar esta parte de aquí que solamente
nos estorba, voy a quitar todo esto que ahorita
no nos sirve y solamente me voy a quedar con que "x"...
déjame quitar todo esto de aquí...
y me voy a quedar con que "x" es igual a
esta expresión de aquí y yo lo que quiero ver
es cuanto vale "x" cuando "y" es igual a 0
y ahora sí, si sustituimos a "y" por 0, me
va a quedar 4 por -9 entre 3, déjame ponerlo
aquí, cuando "y" es 0 entonces "x" es igual
a 4 que multiplica a -9, ok,
esto dividido entre 3 y bueno, puedo dividir 9 entre 3 y
me queda 3, ok, 4 por -3 es lo mismo que -12
y bueno, tiene mucha lógica con lo que veíamos
aquí en la gráfica, cuando "y" vale 0,
"x" vale -12 ó lo podemos poner aquí, estamos
en el punto (-12, 0) y es más,
vamos a escribirlo de una vez en nuestro navegador de internet... déjame traer para acá la página...
ah.... ¿dónde está?...
la tengo justo aquí...
Y entonces déjame escribir que cuando "x"
vale -12, ok, "y" vale 0,
estamos en el punto (-12, 0) y es hora de
comprobar respuesta...
De lujo, estamos bien.